but before we bring on all that heat
let's cool down as we head to
cosmopolitan's ice rink today
is the opening day of the popular
holiday attraction of course jc
is joining us live with a quick look at
what you can expect hey jc
oh careful oh gosh hey rocky
oh no i know this is gonna be so
exciting i am so happy that the ice rink
at the cosmopolitan is open
i've got my hockey stick and i'm gonna
skate on over here i've been practicing
this i think i got this
whoa whoa oh look at this i'm a natural
ice freak is open this is fedora with
the cosmopolitan we're so excited that
you guys are back with us
so give me the details is today the
first day that everyone come down
and do some ice skating thanks for
stopping by jc yes today we're open we
opened just now three o'clock it's
20 for locals discounted pricing come on
down and
celebrate the holidays now of course you
have social distancing and there's
safety protocols in place
correct we've we've got uh we've
expanded the footprint so that we uh to
help ensure
uh social distancing and we've increased
the staff it's an outdoor activity
safety is our utmost concern for our
guests and we want them to safely be
able to celebrate the holidays you've
got skates on can you come out can you
skate with me can we skate can we skate
and talk because
not only do you have ice skating here
you have fire pits as well
because what's the deal with the fire
pits fire pits are available for rent
uh maximum capacity six per and
um you can get food drinks
s'mores by the fireplace and you also
have the uh the date night too
too as well what's what's the date in
which which ties into the big uh
the big board behind me what's the story
on the date classic holiday films
and we're showing them every monday and
tuesday starting at 6 00 p.m right on
the marquee now if someone wants to come
down and and not skate and hang out can
people just come
down here and enjoy the scenery and the
festive fun it is
it is free to come and enjoy the
experience you only need to pay if you
want to skate
now here's the thing i'm feeling very
confident let's say someone's watching
right now
and maybe you're not too confident when
it comes to skating i love that the
i love that the cosplay cup cosmopolitan
provides
these i got about 15 seconds here this
is i mean the ultimate training wheels
everyone looks like a member of the
vegas golden knights when they have
the training wheels we'll send it back
to you guys in the studio the ice rink
at the cosmopolitan is open
yeah it's open and it looks like you can
go swimming too all right thank you so
much jc we will be back
in to check with you at the 4pm newscast
all right